well good morning
on january 5th
our government put in place additional
public health measures to blunt the
transmission of the omicron variant
at the time
we were seeing very concerning trends
emerge
cases were rising steeply
percent positively
nearly hit 40 percent
10 times higher than when omicron was
first identified in ontario
hospitalizations were doubling every
seven days
the data was clear
we needed to dock
today we know it was the right decision
percent positivity has now dropped
to 15.9 percent
new admissions to hospitals
are starting to slow
and patients are spending far less time
in the hospital when admitted
and our health system workforce is
stabilizing with more people coming back
to work than calling in sick
as i said at the time while necessary
the additional measures were always
intended to be time limited
they were one more tool to blunt the
spread of omicron and protect our
hospitals
the evidence tells us
that these measures are working
and that we can expect recent trends to
continue as omicron cases peak this
month
and while we can be confident in how far
we've come
i want to be
crystal clear
we're not out of the woods yet
the coming weeks will continue to pose
real challenges especially to our
hospitals
but these are challenges our hospital
system can manage
we can be confident in our ability to
care for people
to provide hospital beds to those who
need them
and we can be confident that the worst
is behind us
as we look to cautiously ease public
health measures
as we do ontario will repeat the success
of the past reopenings
we're taking a phased approach
with 21 days between each step to make
sure we haven't moved too fast
starting january 31st businesses in
ontario will return to fifty percent
capacity
for the first step arenas concert venues
and theaters will be capped at 500
people social gatherings will increase
to 10 people indoors and 25 people
outdoors
if trends remain stable or improve
ontario will move to the next step on
february 21st
and then march the 14th
minister elliot will provide more
details on what's included in these
steps shortly but before she does
i know will be some who wish we could
move faster
as i said we need to remain cautious
especially with students going back to
class this week
and i know there may be some who say
we're moving too fast
now we want to be absolutely sure these
positive trends continue as we move
forward
and we want to do everything humanly
possible to avoid having to go backwards
if that means pausing between steps for
a few extra days we won't hesitate to do
so
the best way to make sure we keep moving
forward the best way to protect our
progress is by getting vaccinated if you
haven't already done so please get your
first or second shots and if you're
eligible boost up as soon as you can
because so many of you have come forward
for your booster dose
ontario leads the country in third doses
this is fantastic news and something we
should all be proud of
but it shouldn't stop us from wanting to
do more to protect our families our
communities and our hard-fought progress
so please do your part get your shots
it's never too late
thank you and god bless the people of
ontario now i'll pass it over to
minister elliot
thank you premier and good morning
everyone
as the premier mentioned earlier this
month we made the very difficult but
necessary decision to put in place
additional public health measures to
prevent our hospitals from becoming
overwhelmed
at that time our government announced
that these measures would be in place
for at least 21 days subject to trends
in public health and health system
indicators
we are now approaching the end of that
timeline and thanks to the sacrifices of
ontarians and unwavering efforts of our
health care workers these measures are
starting to have an impact
there are some positive signs that we
may be reaching the peak of the omicron
wave in ontario
however
we still need to remain humble and
cautious
that's why as we prepare to safely lift
public health measures we will continue
with a gradual and cautious manner that
has always guided our decisions
in the absence of concerning trends in
public health and health care indicators
ontario will follow a cautious and
phased approach with 21 days between
each step
starting with january 31st 2022 ontario
will begin the process of gradually
easing restrictions in effect under the
modified step two of the roadmap to
reopen
this includes increasing social
gathering limits to 10 people indoors
for social gatherings and 25 people
outdoors
capacity limits will be increased or
maintained at 50 percent for a number of
indoor public settings where proof of
vaccination is required such as
restaurants retail
gyms and religious services
spectator areas at sporting events
concert venues and theaters will be
permitted to operate at 50 percent of
the usual seating capacity or 500 people
with
less
proof of vaccination requirements would
continue to apply in existing settings
should trends remain stable or improve
ontario will move to the next step on
february 21st
at this time we will increase social
gathering limits to 25 people indoors
and 100 people outdoors and remove
capacity limits in indoor public
settings where proof of vaccination is
required
spectator capacity at sporting events
concert venues and theaters will be
permitted at 50 percent capacity
and capacity limits in indoor public
settings were proof vaccination is not
limited is not required will be limited
to the number of people that can
maintain two meters of physical distance
by march 14th we intend to lift capacity
limits in all indoor public settings and
religious services and ceremonies
and increasing social gathering limits
to 50 people indoors with no limits
outdoors
proof of vaccination requirements will
be maintained
recommendations on moving to each step
will continue to be based on the
recommendations of the chief medical
officer of health
and we are committed to remaining
cautious and responsive as we continue
to respond to the omicron variant
as we start to see some hopeful signs
and begin to ease measures
i want to remind ontarians how grateful
we are for their sacrifices to keep one
another safe
and to our health care workers
pharmacists and other essential workers
it has been a long and difficult road
through this pandemic
and it cannot be emphasized enough how
indebted we are to you
as i mentioned yesterday there's no
question we will continue to face
challenges in the weeks ahead
however if we remain steadfast in our
gradual and cautious approach
as more ontarians continue to receive
their vaccine and we begin to roll out
antiviral treatments
and as we continue to use the full
resources of our health care system
i am confident that we can manage the
challenges before us
thank you
before we take questions from the phone
we'll move to the floor first
hi premier matthew bingley global news
uh
last october you presented a plan that
had a very ambitious opening plan that
saw at the end of march
uh the the loosening of restrictions to
the point where
you were saying that masking would no
longer be necessary and vaccine
passports would no longer be necessary
under this plan it appears that march
14th
vac's passports are still necessary at
that point
and uh
there's i didn't see a mention on
masking
my question to both you and dr moore is
do you think that you were overly
ambitious with that original plan
and do you see a point where
uh in in cold weather
where we see cases rise such as next
fall that these steps would probably be
necessary the vax passport and masking
to continue
well first of all back in october we
didn't see the the spread of omicron
and we we saw the the spread taking off
at the beginning of january that changed
the game and i'm 100 uh
confident that that was the right
decision when they gave us the data
and uh you know there was three things
that we we had to focus on
uh first of all we we saw the the spread
the positivity rate was 40 percent those
are staggering numbers four out of 10
people
were
getting omicron
now we we see it drop down to 15.9
percent so that that's positive we we
saw the cases of the hospitalizations
where they they were they were doubling
every single week now we're seeing that
ease and another big big factor was the
absenteeism of our healthcare workers
but not just our healthcare workers uh
other uh businesses right across the
province so we're we're seeing a
positive trend we're still very cautious
and i always say we aren't out of the
woods yet but we're taking a cautious
approach to move forward
and i'm confident
that we're going to
move forward cautiously and get things
back to normal as quickly as possible
dr moore do you have anything to add
no i think the premier's response was uh
absolutely right on um in october we had
no understanding uh that
omicron would be declared a new variant
of concern november 26th we had a good
plan in place for delta and thanks to
all ontarians they were
getting immunized they were following
all the basic public health measures to
ensure safety in our community so we've
responded to a new variant quite
appropriately sadly we've had to put
public health measures in play at
present to best protect ontarians in the
health care system uh again thank
sacrifices they've made it's made a
difference our health system has been
able to provide the right care at the
right time for any patient with covid19
certainly we're at capacity in the
healthcare system we've made sacrifices
for
elective surgeries to be able to provide
that capacity but all ontarians are
receiving the care that's required at
present and thank them once again for
their um for their sacrifices and
we have to be adaptive to uh any new uh
variant uh and ontarians have done that
um for omicron uh we do uh see light at
the end of this phase of the pandemic as
the premier has outlined
and we do see hope that the sacrifices
have been worth it by the businesses
affected
and like any public health measure they
have to have a time limited
place
and
now that we've
anticipated the health system being able
to provide the right care at the right
time for all patients in ontario we're
absolutely prepared to remove the
measures uh in a cautious and gradual
staged and phased approach
premier
the cfib says that one in five
businesses is on the verge of financial
ruin and collapse
i i know that you've already pointed to
some of the supports that have already
been presented but they are saying that
even with restrictions lifted consumer
confidence isn't there and they will
suffer going forward what more does your
government need to do
to add financial support to make sure
that they don't
collapse
well first of all my my heart breaks for
the businesses i'm i'm a business minded
person own a business i get it i
understand how tough it is to to meet
payrolls and meet the the sales coming
in and
and meeting all the challenges but we've
stepped up two tunes of billions and
billions of dollars we just put out a
ten thousand dollar grant we're also uh
making sure that they were taking care
of their electricity costs and other
areas of support from the federal
government as as well uh folks you know
when we get back out there i encourage
you to go in and support your local
business go go out to the restaurant
even at the the 50 please
take a night out at least once a week
and go to your local restaurant and
support them either take out or or
you're able to sit inside but make no
mistake about it i i i understand i
fully understand the pain they've gone
through
but we'll we'll come back we'll come
back strong
out of this
our economy is strong i'm going to say
it'll be like the roaring 20s
we've seen 160 000 more people employed
uh right as we speak right now than we
did prior to the pandemic
we've created the environment for for
companies to come from all over the
world and and open up businesses here uh
we we need more people
we need another 315 000 uh people to
fill the jobs
so i'm confident about the economy i'm
feeling very confident we're going to
cautiously open up and we're going to
get back to normal as soon as we
possibly can
i can tell the business owners
i i i can't stand closing them down i
know the doc knows that i know the
minister knows it
but health health is a priority and i
follow directions and advice from our
health team
and that's that's what was able to get
us
through the last few weeks
okay we're ready to move to the phone
lines for questions first question
please
from rob ferguson with the toronto star
please go ahead
hi premier all and or doctor moore i'm
just wondering um
since in in the past you've had to kind
of pause or delay some of these
reopenings i'm wondering what
specifically
you would be
looking at that would kind of be the
trip wire
for having to pause or temporarily halt
these kind of measures what are the key
things you're looking at i'll pass out
dr moore
thanks rob so just in particular it's
not one
number that we're monitoring uh it is a
series of data points uh as the premier
announced uh the percentage of tests
that are positive is on the decline at
15 percent so that is one indicator
we're following very closely as well the
ability to care for ontarians in the
intensive care unit setting as well as
in the hospital
thank you to all the health care workers
that continue to provide care we're at
100 capacity for the medical and
surgical beds but
we are providing care for covid patients
in the right place at the right time the
other metric is the number of outbreaks
in long-term care facilities in
particular because
patients have to move eventually from
the acute care sector back into
long-term care or from long-term care
back into the acute care sector so those
are some of the metrics that we're
following um as well as the ability to
care for individuals in the health
sector in the in the premier already
mentioned the number of people that are
not in the work
called in sick
we're seeing improvement in those
metrics and they're plateauing
in terms of the hospital use we
anticipate by the 31st that there will
be ongoing improvements but february
will be difficult as well we absolutely
anticipate the need to have continued
icu capacity for for patients uh and
hence uh the premier's call to continue
to get immunized to continue to come
forward for the third doses is uh will
be important every day going forward 11
days to the opening um and we want a
million more ontarians coming forward we
can immunize more than a hundred
thousand a day so important that anyone
with an underlying medical illness in
ontario get their third dose especially
those that are 50 and older and there
are appointments available across
ontario to do that over the next several
days so please take advantage of the
availability of vaccine
follow-up
yes thank you doctor you were mentioning
that everyone with kovitz getting the
care they need but a lot of people with
needing cancer and other
surgeries and heart procedures and
whatnot are are still on this
this uh pause when will you lift that so
that hospitals can get more and max back
to normal and
when do you think under the timelines
for reopening that you'll be able to get
back to
broader pcr testing than we're having
now was mostly limited to healthcare
workers and people at high risk
well it's very impor unfortunate that we
had to provide directive two to pause
non-emergent non-urgent surgeries if
people do have a life-threatening
condition of course they will still
receive the care that they need but we
know that many people are upset and
frustrated at having their surgeries
pushed off yet again
we want to get back on track with them
as soon as we can but that as you know
both hospitalizations and admissions to
icu are lagging indicators so we don't
expect the peak of the
admissions to icu to happen until
about mid-february early first second
week of february
so as soon as we can see that the
numbers are going down both in terms of
admissions to hospital and in terms of
intensive care admissions then we'll be
able to get back on track with those
surgeries and procedures because as i
said this is a very difficult decision
to make
but one that we had to do to
preserve our hospital capacity in terms
of beds but also in terms of health
human resources but i will ask dr moore
to perhaps comment further on that
thank you rob again for the
testing strategy we take
advice from the expert panel on testing
and from our laboratory partners we do
have a good capacity within the pcr
system uh to
review our testing criteria at present
again therefore uh uh the most
vulnerable long-term care facilities
hospitals those that uh need treatment
those with comorbidities and first
nations inuit metis but we're regularly
reviewing the criteria for pcr testing
again this province has also been very
aggressive in making available rapid
antigen tests so 3.9 million distributed
this week through our education partners
so we're going to try to have a balanced
approach between the access to rat tests
both prioritized
but also having a population level
access to rats as well as to the pcr so
going forward we want to balance between
those two testing modalities uh clearly
the more labor-intensive and the more
difficult to get so you have to go to an
assessment center you have to wait get
the swab done for pcr testing
we're limiting it specifically to those
high risk
populations and settings
and i hope the public as we have more
rats generally available will take
advantage of them because i i do believe
they're much more convenient done in the
calm of your home
and you have an answer within minutes
instead of waiting several days for the
pcr results
next question
your next question comes from richard
southern with city news 680 please go
ahead
hi premier good morning premier you said
at the beginning of the month that
restaurants gyms and movie theaters were
closing to protect hospitals can you
then tell us today why restaurants gyms
and movies are reopening before elective
surgery is resuming
well i'll just repeat what i
said earlier on richard
there was three areas of focus
number one
is when we we saw the
hospitalizations double every single
week
we saw the positivity rate go right up
to 40 percent
now we've seen it drop down to 15.9
percent and everyone saw the absenteeism
in your own workplace not to mention the
the health care sector you know we're
doing everything we can to make sure we
uh bolster the the health care system uh
keeping keep in mind folks i'm gonna go
back a little bit here the liberal
government fired sixteen hundred nurses
our health care system was not in good
shape uh when we took office since then
we've hired over six thousand seven
hundred health care workers we're going
to be bringing in another six thousand
in march we're putting billions and
billions of dollars
into the health care system we want to
make sure that we're prepared for any
future pandemic we've put in billion
tens of billions of dollars into
infrastructure and building new
hospitals right across this province and
we're going to continue to invest in our
health care but we can't do it alone no
province can do it alone
since i've been elected we've been on
the federal government for the cht the
canadian health transfers
we are paying as ontarians uh 78 of the
cost uh the federal government and it's
not just this federal government it's
prior federal governments i don't care
if it's conservative or liberal
they're pitching in 22
that's unacceptable every single premier
is in line with making sure that the
federal government pays their fair share
of health care and it's not one-time
funding that we're looking for we need
continuous funding non-stop until we can
hire more health care workers until we
can take care of our nurses until we can
continue uh bringing in new technology
and and building new hospitals but i can
tell you every single premier is in line
on this we're going to have a meeting
today with all the premiers we need the
federal government to step up it's very
simple we will not be able to move
forward not only as a province as a
country
with with the uh the federal government
pitching in 22
and putting the vast majority of the
burden on the backs of our of the
provinces
follow-up
okay follow up for dr moore dr moore
there's a letter posted online appearing
to be from you addressed to the niagara
region chief medical officer of health
in which you quote express concern with
measures he's taking with schools in
that region including weekly co2
monitoring in classrooms the dismissal
of cohorts if there's a positive case
and the use of medical exemption notes
for masks is that letter accurate sir
cannot local medical officers of health
make their own decisions and dr moore
what's so wrong with these measures
oh so we meet with our medical officers
health on a regular basis we have
consultation to them from this office to
local public health and i thank all the
local public health officials for all
their work they're doing to protect
the health of their communities both
through vaccination and case and contact
management and outbreak management
what i'm trying to have across ontario
is a consistent and persistent approach
so that parents school boards families
can expect the same level of protection
and care
and so i did have a conversation with
niagara to understand a different
approach that medical officer of health
informed me of why they're making them
and that dialogue continues
and i have the similar dialogue with
health units across this province
through my regional associate chief
medical officers of health so i think
all ontarians should be assured that
we're in regular partnership with our
local public health agencies that we
communicate we collaborate with them and
we try to ensure consistent and
persistent approaches across ontario
next question
your next question comes from kelly
botello with chch news please go ahead
hello this question is also for dr moore
on the same topic of that letter that
you sent doctor here gene what are your
biggest concerns with those measures
that
the niagara health unit is implementing
and how dr hiroji is managing to return
to school
so
the consultation that we had with his
office was basically about the public
health measures that are in place and
the return to school we want consistent
and persistent messaging across ontario
we
have reviewed the science tables
recommendations the importance of the
mental physical social and educational
needs of our students and the desire to
keep them in the classroom as much as
possible
and some of the recommendations that he
had put in play
could have
increased the amount of absenteeism with
students so it seemed to go contrary to
the recommendations of the science table
and our pediatric experts and our
education experts so i just sought
clarity from the medical office of
health i also sought clarity on some of
the recommendations
and policies that he that they put in
place in a workplace
given that schools are workplace for
teachers
and and jurisdictionally uh public
health physicians typically don't get
involved in workplaces that's more
ministry of labor so uh the purpose of
the communication was to seek clarity uh
to concede to seek ongoing consultation
and to be supportive of our local
medical officers of health
which
we try to coordinate regular meetings
and this issue had not been brought up
with us in the past
follow-up
thank you and do you think
or would you encourage people to dine in
at restaurants or work out at gyms when
the restrictions do listen
so there are safety measures that are in
place in all of the restaurants and all
of these physic facilities including
masking distancing hand hygiene
and point of
visit verification of immune
immunization status so all the measures
that we've put in place will remain uh
we do believe a safe and cautious
opening at 50 capacity uh will build
confidence in ontarians and decrease the
risk we think it's proportionate to the
risk at present
and as the premier has said we need to
have a balanced approach that recognizes
the importance of someone maybe being
able to keep their businesses open to
generate a living
to have a place of employment against
the risk of this virus
and i do think it's proportionate and
balanced to have them open on the 31st
with the measures that we put in place
across
all these workplaces which ensure the
best safety that we can
given the infectiousness of this virus
next question
your next question comes from allison
jones with the canadian press please go
ahead
hi premier with businesses that require
proof of vaccination set to reopen soon
are you looking at all at updating the
requirements for the vaccine certificate
to three doses from two
not right at this point
follow-up
all right um i'm also wondering about
long-term care restrictions are you
looking at using any of the visitor
restrictions
in long-term care
i'll pass that over to
dr dr moore
so it would be up to the ministry of
long-term care to make any changes in
any of their directions we consult with
them
and any removal of measures that have
been put in place would be proportionate
and balanced to the risk the risk still
remains relatively high we
clearly are seeing a number of outbreaks
across long-term care facilities both
and positivity in workers as well as in
their clients and patients
uh and and i think it's important to
keep those restrictions that are in
place uh until we see uh
significant improvement uh in the
transmissibility and activity of omicron
in our community so please bear with us
thank you for the sacrifices you're
making we we know
these have an effect
on the well-being of some individuals in
these facilities
but we also need to balance
those with the risks of transmission in
those facilities so we
we review them on a regular basis uh and
ensure that we remove them in a timely
and
safe fashion
and meet with the ministry of long-term
care
on a regular basis
with a formal meeting every friday
afternoon to review all measures
we'll take our final question from the
floor
mr premier this is a question i've asked
um whenever there's a
trauma there's a question i've asked a
lot of premiers
right now there's a a incident uh
happening in brampton
and mississauga that um is very tragic
um
first of all your thoughts and then how
can you reach out to the uh community
that's traumatized right now yeah they
they just uh briefly literally before i
walked in the door my heart just breaks
you know for for the family and the
whole community what what a tragedy
it is and we'll we'll be there i'll
speak to the mayor patrick brown
uh today reach out to see if there's
anything uh we can do
but what what a loss
it's terrible absolutely terrible
thanks everyone okay thank you
you